want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
become more confident with my friend
lisa bilia you couldn't have possibly
convinced me
that when i was 14 years old i'd
eventually find confidence
you couldn't have convinced me that
actually like myself
that one day i'd actually have
self-esteem
that one day i'd be hosting my own show
with pink hair
and a black and red silky jacket now if
i knew this
would have done anything differently
would i have stopped wearing baggy
clothes and embraced my embarrassingly
small chest size
would i have stopped trying to be
understated with my hair and embrace my
quirky side
would have started to wear makeup and
finally embrace my female sexuality
now guys i really really think about
this because the truth is
yes it held me back the things i could
have done differently if i could have
had confidence
would have been astronomical so buckle
up
and hold on to your seats because you're
about to get a boost of confidence
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one switch your perspective
the best place to start is talk to me
about what confidence is
so you know a lot of people
misunderstand confidence and they think
it's an outward bravado like
you and i can perform and be in front of
people and this is performance
confidence
that is not necessarily confidence
because sometimes the quietest people in
the room are confident
so when i talk about confident as f i
mean inside and outside
let's talk about what it truly is it's
an over all
sense of feeling like you're going to
prevail feeling comfortable with
yourself
at any given time alone in a room
walking into anywhere
and it's not to say that confident
people don't have moments but those
moments are so fleeting and so quickly
and self-talked out
that they're not lasting and you know
seeping away at your soul
all right so what are the things that
you've noticed confident people do have
you know there's several so confident
people are often the most authentic
they don't give a [ __ ] about what other
people think of them that's the ultimate
in not caring about what someone's
opinions are of you
they are also they're kind confident
people
are often more successful they prevail
because they
it never hurts to ask they're not afraid
to speak up if you don't speak up in
life
from the bedroom to the boardroom you're
not going to get what you want
so a confident person will admit either
shortcomings or moments where they
they need to learn something they also
it's really interesting confident people
on so many levels take any kind of
challenge or hit
as a lesson they don't internalize it
and beat themselves up
you know what i mean so confident people
will often get through these challenges
it's a very like primal ancestral thing
back to like the first book i wrote
paleo thyroid solution talking about
ancestral health but
listen we need to be valued by a tribe
you can be a confident person and just
be a wonderful friend
okay to people and be loved and valued
my book is not meant to be like go out
and be a badass you can be a wonderful
confident stay-at-home
wife but guess what you might have to
stand up to some
kid's mother at that pta meeting you're
gonna need confidence for that
you're gonna need self-esteem for that
you still are need you need to navigate
through life with this or you're not
gonna get what you want and
people want to be around confident
people the one thing that i've learned
is first of all they're most admired
not just because of their authenticity
but confident people often get
done when i used to be an employer i
would rather hire a confident individual
than someone who actually had the skill
set and not the personality
because confident people are proactive
you know they take on situations you
know that
they're confident in their ability to
learn a thing even if they don't know it
so you're trying to be confident you're
trying to work on yourself you're doing
everything that you just said and now
you've got other people coming to you
being the naysayers how do you react and
what are
what is your advice in those situations
it depends on how severe if it's a
stranger or a loved one okay but
in fact take me through both yeah so um
it depends like there's times when i've
spoken up to a stranger for example
a stranger asked me what i what i do
like hey what do you do and i said i'm a
writer
now just forever watching if you're in
la and you say you're a writer like
absolutely nobody cares right and
they're like they're usually like
whatever like what have you done they
want your whole resume you know if you
say you're a writer anywhere else in the
country they're like oh my god that's so
cool what are you right you know
people are more interested so i said i'm
a writer and he said
literally verbatim he said this he goes
okay so are you like a real writer that
makes money at it
or do you like work at starbucks and do
another job but like just right on the
side
and i said that's rude as [ __ ] dude
would you go up to a real estate agent
and go do you just have your real estate
agent license and not sell houses but
like live at home or do you actually
like make money at it
and he goes oh well that's different i
go no it's not dude
it's just rude and i said but the good
thing for me is that when i come across
a naysayer like you
i use it to fuel my confidence and
you've just propelled me
to a level of success so thank you very
much so
i also choose to believe i think i would
love it if everyone did
that when you get hit like that from
people
you gotta use it to fuel like i just
have this belief system that
when you get hit at like that you're
just raising me up you've just propelled
me another level
and i always say it's not necessarily
about proving them wrong it's about
proving yourself
awesome so we can stop sharing our
as steve harvey i think it was his quote
stop sharing your million dollar ideas
with hundred dollar people
if you keep coming up against the brick
wall your sister keeps being
unencouraging or skeptical about
whatever you're doing stop sharing stuff
with them
until you've either achieved it but even
once you achieved it you might get
downered by that person
what about someone that isn't
necessarily confident and is in the
process of trying to develop their
confidence and they have
a one two three punch hit and they're
like i can't take any more of it all
these people just don't believe in me i
barely believe in myself
so maybe i'm not good good writer maybe
i'm not going to be able to do this
what advice do you give to those people
yeah you know and i talk about this in
detail in the book in little mini ways
which is
that's where you really have to sit with
that and go first of all am i going to
continue to share
my dreams and my hopes and my like
creative ideas or whatever it is
or my business ideas with this skeptic
with this downer with this person
you got to stop start there and then if
you don't have anyone else then you get
an unbiased coach or therapist or
someone who can encourage you
or you try to find a new tribe trying to
manifest a new tribe of people
but also too it's like in that moment
what's really true there
are you going to allow their opinion
of you to dictate your success that's
what you are doing so you might get hit
a bunch but that can be an indicator to
go okay you know what maybe i need to
kind of keep this close to the vest
maybe not to share this idea if i keep
coming up against this brick wall my
friend mary keeps
you know not believing in me you know i
have a quote in the book it's a it's a
take on a finnish composer's quote who
said no one ever built a statue to a
critic and my version is no one ever
built a statue to a skeptic
you know what i mean what if you say
like oh i'm really thinking about
starting a new business
and your friend's like ugh i don't know
you know be careful like 50 percent of
new businesses fail
well bad i'm going to be on the 50 of
the side of the people that
win again you have to turn this around
you know like
this is so again you can get a coach
like me or anyone else to to kind of
talk you through the stuff but these are
about like you're sitting with someone
going
why am i aggravated why do i feel put
down and usually it's because uh
so-and-so doesn't believe in me
and it's not about proving them right
but it's about proving yourself
awesome because if you're always trying
to prove everyone wrong
again you are still projecting outward
that everyone else's opinions are
more important than the opinion you have
of yourself so you have to develop this
opinion of yourself
everyone has some area that they're
confident in whether you know
you could be like a wonderful friend you
could be a wonderful mother that's
enough
it doesn't need to be like
accomplishments and a resume you know
and again this is for everybody because
people
just have issues speaking up and if you
don't ask
you're back to where you were before you
have to get okay with some rejection
you got to learn to be okay with people
coming at you and being downers it's not
to say that it's not a hit
i just want to do one spot like that on
something that just you just killed like
the 50 percent
a fail and you're like but why am i in
the failure bucket why am i not in the
the success bucket and you even said it
all comes down to perspective
i'm such a advocate for perspective
because i think
literally by just switching that like
all right you're in the 50
that fail now how do you feel and if i
told you in the 50 that succeed how do
you feel
completely freaking i just felt rule
number two get to know yourself
i always grew up heavy set like larger
than most people in my class
or my my family like the younger girls
in my family
my immediate family mum and my dad they
never really made me feel that way like
in all of my videos when i was younger
i'm in front of the camera like super
happy
my mom was like an instructor like a
fitness instructor she had like six-pack
abs
when i was growing up yeah she was super
fair she would
kind of drag me to all of her classes
but i noticed it most when i started
going to school
obviously you end up seeing people
around you and the girls around you and
the type of people that end up being
liked or disliked and you realize that
actually ends up being a lot to do with
your physical
form i want to go to what you said about
your mom um having six-pack abs yeah
like
did that did it dawn on you at the time
like was it any
envy or did it make you feel badly or
you don't you would like no i was just a
happy-go-lucky kid and it was cool that
my mom had abs
no i definitely felt it like you
definitely feel it from a young age and
emotionally it was more when people
would make comments about it
or when you can't fit into things or
when you
see yourself in like a video with the
rest of your family or your cousins and
you're like
the chubby kid in the corner you know
you don't but the confidence level i
think only changed when i got to school
and it was there was i was surrounded by
girls who i thought
were more beautiful than me or skinnier
than me and it's so weird i always feel
that
now looking back thinking that fitness
was always related to how skinny you
were like that was my
my image ever growing up that's all i
thought that to be fit that means you
have to be really really slim
and it wasn't necessarily because of my
mum but it's just what you end up
growing up looking at all over the
places
women wanting to be super slim and in my
eyes that meant for me to be fit i had
to be skinny
so how did you not let that erode your
self-worth
or did it erode yourself worse i think
it definitely did because growing up
your self-worth i feel is based on
everybody around you
when you're a teenager how many guys
like you or whether the guy you like
likes you back
that ends up defining whether you love
yourself or whether your friends love
you
you're not stable you have no rooting
and so everything that you base your
love for yourself on ends up being
external and so i definitely had ups and
downs of
of really thinking i was something
when somebody liked me and then when
somebody didn't like me or my friends
decided not to be friends with me
i would dislike myself and so everything
was based on external validation
for sure and how did you stop that loop
then or when do
you remember the first time you
recognized it that it was a loop yeah i
felt that way for a long time that i
felt something was missing i knew
that my love for myself could not be
based on other people there had to be
something else that i could have a
foundation of okay fine there can be ups
and downs but i never go down to a low
where i don't love myself
and i definitely think meditation was
the turning point for me
and i felt that because it was the one
time in the day where i would end up
spending time with myself
like you i feel like people don't do
that we spend time on everything to do
with hair
and makeup and clothes and on other
people
looking at other people talking to other
people um
but i felt like i wasn't spending any
time actually thinking who am i
like i don't know who i am and i feel
like in a relationship whether it's with
yourself or whether it's with somebody
else
you have to know yourself to love
yourself we never get into relationships
with people or friendships with people
without knowing them
you can't fall in love with someone
without knowing them and so i felt like
okay who am i like i actually don't know
who i am i don't know what i like i
don't know why i dislike everything that
i like or dislike is based on other
people
um everything that i like about myself
is based on other people's lives
exactly and so everything is to do with
oh they like it so that must be who i am
and so i thought meditation was the
first time or just journaling was the
first time i started writing down things
about things i like about myself or
don't like about myself
and so it created more of like a
relationship with with me
i was having a relationship with myself
finally rather than
my perception of myself because of other
people rule number three
show up take me through let's say some
strategies of like someone's in there
right now they want to be confident they
want to show up in the world they want
to
they've got all these dreams but they
don't feel like they've got the
confidence to do it
what are those first steps that
practically people can actually do
yeah absolutely so i talk a lot about
rebuilding self-trust
because i talk about self-betrayal that
i think a lot of us begin to feel or we
we lack trust in ourselves whether it's
because we haven't consistently said
done what we said we were going to do or
we find ourselves stuck in the same
patterns before long
you repeat that enough we become someone
on some deep level
as i say it that we don't trust
ourselves and i see
confident or trus self trust as being
the bridge to confidence so when i talk
about i build this process
right in with building habits so you'll
often hear the language that i use
is a small daily promise that's just an
intention
small emphasis on small because what i
do know about humans we set a bar too
high so small daily promise if we're
talking breath work five deep belly
breaths
could be waking up five minutes earlier
could be
you know doing one new small thing in
any given day whatever it is
emphasis on small because the higher the
expectation
the more quickly we travel down the path
of lacking confidence again
because an expectation bar that set too
high that i don't meet or i don't meet
as consistently as i would like to
meet it i start to erode even further
that confidence so when i said change is
hard for all of us
in our subconscious and the most
simplest way to think about it as crazy
as it sounds your subconscious just like
mine just like everyone in this room
our subconscious has logged everything
that's happened to us thus far in our
life
and we'll continue to do that until
we're no longer on this planet which is
a lot of crap
so to make sense of it and this is a
little silly like thing i say but i
think this is helpful
it's we have a little avatar in us and
yours has a little lisa might as well
nicole
it's memorized us it knows all of our
habits behaviorally it knows all of our
habitual thoughts
and knows how those thoughts make us
feel so logically
right you might be saying okay whoever's
listening this new thing
that i want to do small promise is going
to get me to the goal that i want
when you go to do this new thing our
subconscious registers our choices in a
very black and white way
with the one end being familiar equals
safe
good unfamiliar equals unsafe possibly
dangerous band to be avoided at all cost
never do it again run away as quickly as
possible and then one of two things
happen
either an endless i call it mental
chatter we'll have an endless litany of
reasons why never to do this thing again
and or because sometimes we get both in
my body i start to feel agitated
sometimes will describe it
some people will describe it as i'm just
crawling out of my skin it might just
start to feel weird just not like i'm
used to feeling
so when one of those two things happen
before we know it
we begin to listen and we begin to steer
right back to that memorized comfort
zone because comfort
for the subconscious is just familiar
and it does that to keep us
safe because it's predictable because it
knows the results all of that gets us
and
it's okay with it even if logically
we're not okay with it
it's okay with it so when and i say this
too because
i prepare people when you go to make
this new or keep
this daily promise three days from now
three months from now maybe even three
years from now
your subconscious might be telling you
why not to
so making sure and giving people the
tools to throw away the expectation
that they're going to have a
cheerleading squad this time or
even maybe feel like they want to
because i think a lot of people
also wait to change to feel like they
want to or to feel motivated
or to look for something to change
internally and that's not going to
happen
so showing up keeping those promises and
acknowledging to yourself that you are
keeping those promises that seem so
small but i think most of us humans i
used to do this too at the end of the
day
i would give me the litany and focus on
everything i didn't do
and not well what did i what did i do
how did i show up for myself
and the more times you show that
alignment between what i said i was
going to do
and what i do you repeat that enough
you begin to trust yourself and then you
repeat that enough those same promises
and then you begin i believe to feel
confident in yourself which is just
i know i do what i say and then i think
a little more repetition of that turns
into empowerment that i've been speaking
of which the simplest way i define it is
i believe i can do anything and then i
become a really powerful creator
and it starts literally as small as it
sounds with a small daily promise that
you are keeping
regardless of what your mind is telling
you to do your mind and your thoughts
are not your intuition
right so don't believe them all of the
time rule number four
fake it till you make it how do you
build that
um personality to
be bold continuously if you keep getting
knocked down right because
like you said most people do it one to
three times because getting rejected
sucks it hurts
upsetting so one time all right maybe i
can come back from it two times and
three times it's like all right maybe
i'm not
um maybe this isn't right for me but how
do you then stay
the fourth the fifth the sixth time and
then be bold enough to keep leading
because you went to la right um
where you'd got a job offer and it was a
great job offer but
the caveat was you had to wear a suit
and you were like
i don't freaking want to wear a suit so
you you have
the audacity to call them up and be like
yeah i'm going to take it but i'm not
going to wear a suit which i love by the
way
right right how do you develop that
skill
and what do you tell yourself in order
to get there
i think the real answer is like like i
was saying a little bit earlier
was honestly just practice you fake it
until you make it right you'll be
like i can i can give you a ton of
cliches believe it to achieve it make it
to me make it whatever you want to say
and the react or just do it nike the
reality is
unfortunately that is the truth right
like you have to
put yourself out there to have the
opportunity in the first place
and don't focus on a million things i
think a lot of times people
focus on a lot of things and then they
don't win at anything right
be deliberate say this is one thing i
really want to achieve this is the one
job i want this is the one
the one you know the person i want to
date don't just take what's by default
in front of you
right so i like i say like chase what
you want don't take what you get
so if you fail say to yourself okay you
know what i'm gonna
mentally prepare i'm gonna try this ten
times so if you fail those one to three
times
know that that's part of the game and
then give yourself that other seven
times to
attempt something and like the idea also
from that
is you get comfortable with rejection
like you're putting yourself in the
situation where you're getting
comfortable with people saying no to you
comfortable with the rejection like with
keanu reeves
yeah i got keanu reeves to do the demo
tape to go and go
to to send it into much music and did i
did it get looked at
yes did i get did i get close yes
but i never got the job right never got
the job
so but something else happened from that
opportunity
right so i think it's a mindset you've
got to put yourself in that mindset that
you know what
maybe the answer will be no maybe you
will fail
this one time but that's going to lead
you to a yes
and to a something successful if you
just keep on persevering and keep on
pursuing
that's really what it is it's like it's
like tweaking your brain and tweaking
your mind
to being okay with that no and that
rejection in that moment
knowing that it's gonna turn around and
kind of
morph into something later on rule
number five practice
disruptive gratitude i have this
practice that i do called disruptive
gratitude where it's saying
like listing out like what's something
i'm grateful for say i'm saying okay my
body you know okay i'm great for my body
um why and then the second question is
why am i grateful for it
listing out why and okay like i can i
can walk right now and then thinking of
like all
the people that maybe can't walk right
now you know everyone's like have
self-love
right and i heard that for so long and i
was like well how like
how do i actually develop that i know i
have to have it i'm supposed to have it
but like
if i i don't like looking at myself in
the mirror right now i don't like who i
am i don't feel good about myself i
don't feel confident
how the hell am i supposed to have this
self-love you know and so
i love talking about i talk a lot about
like practical tools that literally have
changed me
i think it's really different to say
okay i'm grateful then to be like
to actually feel and embody gratitude
the point where you get goosebumps and
chills and tears
you know but it's been a constant
practice of habits patterns
uh you know every single day for a very
long time
just as if we practice the negative i
might say negative but the non-helpful
right it's not helpful for me i like
thinking of things
and so i think so many people talk about
positive and negative thoughts
and that's great but it didn't really
land in me what really landed in me was
when
i started thinking about it is this a
productive thought or a non-productive
thought yeah like if my goal
is to be happy with who i am my goal is
to have self-love
like is this thought helping me get
there yeah and if it's not then how can
i
you know disrupt it so it does uh and
that's been something that's been really
helpful for me rule number six take the
first step
they talk about the confidence gap have
you ever read that book i have it's a
great book for anyone who wants to read
it
they talk about that gap will only get
bigger
if we sit in the fear and a lot of
people say well i'm not confident enough
yet
to do the thing i'm waiting to you know
be more prepared have more
certifications
whatever right all the things but the
more we sit in the waiting
the bigger that gap gets the bigger the
fear gets
because the fear goes up see you're
still not ready you weren't ready last
month you're not ready this month
you're definitely not going to be ready
next month and that little conversation
gets louder and louder
and the gap gets bigger and bigger and
then five years down the road we're like
oh
i had this dream five years ago to do
what that person is doing and i should
have done it
but i didn't and then that becomes our
life so
the way out of that is literally step
first
confidence second so people think it's
confidence first
step second but it's not it's step first
in the fear without knowing what's gonna
happen
totally like okay let's just see let's
figure it out
and you build confidence through that
through going okay i stepped i didn't
die
everything's okay that was actually kind
of fun
let me take another step and that's how
we actually develop our confidence is
through the steps into the unknown
rule number seven swap anxiety with
excitement
another study um and what they did was
they wanted to look at anxiety
and we're talking about awkwardness i
think that some very similar
kind of feelings in there anxious
awkward um
shy what this study did is they wanted
to know that exact question
is what do you do if you are anxious but
you gotta
fake it right you've got you've got to
find confidence why they didn't use the
word faking
so what they realized was that anxiety
and anxiousness is a sister emotion
to excitement okay so when you think
about when you're anxious what happens
in your body
you get little butterflies in your
stomach you start to kind of sweat you
get a little bit of dry mouth
you feel a little bit hot and sweaty
that's anxious your hearts like
complications now explain excitement to
me yeah exactly the same exactly
yeah in your body yeah anxiety and
excitement
feel very similar the cousin or sister
emotion is there a way to reframe
how you're viewing your own anxiety as
potential excitement and here's what
they did they took people
and they had them uh come into the lab
and they gave them a task and the task
was cruel
in my opinion what was it they had them
sing
don't stop believing into a karaoke
machine so they were rated for their
accuracy of words accuracy of notes
accuracy of
like high pressure i know okay so let's
see i think i forget the numbers right
so they had them sing
this character song but they had three
different groups okay the first group
walked in sung the song done control
group second group
walked in and they had to say i'm
anxious
out loud and then sing and the last
group had to say
i'm excited and then sing a song that's
it
no no prep no mental nothing just saying
those words of course the i'm excited
group
outperformed out sung and actually
enjoyed the experience
more in the group that just said i'm
anxious
this is i think such good news
it means that we are in control of how
we view
our own anxiety our own awkwardness rule
number eight surround yourself with good
people
you wrote a blog yes and you said there
are basically six keys
to building your confidence that you
have to address yeah and you said
diet are you anti-social
hormonal imbalance jealousy new goals
and
treating yourself tell me which one do
you think is the most important one
that for people that offer you to adopt
in order for you to build your
confidence to go from being a gymnast
to dancing to now what you do oh my
goodness
i would say kind of building on the
anti-social
okay um i did not expect that one yeah
90
of your confidence has to come with from
within
but the other 10
comes from who you're around and if
you're around
the wrong people if you're putting
yourself in situations where
you're too insecure to put yourself in
new
situations if you are
reading blogs if you are reading social
media and
letting that kind of seep in it just
kills confidence
and i feel like when i talk
to young women and young girls who are
struggling with self-confidence issues
and eating disorders or whatever it may
be
i always say the the way i found a way
out of it
was to surround myself with people who
cared about me and who could reinforce
the things that my mind didn't want to
tell me
and if you're anti-social if you
don't want to surround yourself with
people who are telling you good things
it's just going
to make your problems bigger rule number
nine be the best at what you do
you were um working at a news station
correct and you heard news anchors they
were saying like oh she'd never get a
job oh yeah
so i put on the hijab when i was 16
and it was just amidst this like
identity crisis like no one in my family
thought i was going to keep it on
you can't be on tv with it on and that's
the one thing that i knew i wanted to do
since i was a kid
so when i did put it on i was like maybe
this is going to give me the same
strength that i see like in my mom and
my sister
my grandmother like maybe this is like
the thing that i need that's going to
make me feel stronger
and so i put it on and right after i put
it on
i ended up getting a job offer at a
newspaper and i was like wait maybe i
can still do this
like accomplish accomplish this dream
while wearing it
so i started college at 16 and i made a
promise on my first day of school that i
would
uh do any and everything that felt true
to me like i wanted to make sure that i
was joining every club i was
doing every activity and eventually
every single step that i took to stay
true to myself led me to
jobs and radio and then jobs and
television
um and i eventually like got my first
job at a local television station
simply from like maintaining this sense
of identity and strength and
storytelling
and i also realized that
i would have to be the absolute best
journalist
possible so that people wouldn't just
shoo me away when i applied and i had i
found mentors who wanted to train me
to literally be so good at my skills
that no one could ever say no to me and
part of me has to give credit to the
fact that like
because i put on the hijab i made sure i
like
maximized all my potential because
there's a chance that if i never put it
on that i would have been like oh
i can just be like a good journalist and
i'll still get a job and i wouldn't have
like felt like the fire to work so hard
and so the second you own your 100 like
version of yourself whatever is true to
yourself and you realize that maybe that
doesn't fit in
with society's typical standards
especially when it comes to television
because everybody's cookie cutter looks
the same
when it comes to news reporting you have
to carry your
have sir an outfit certain no jewelry
certain hairstyles whatever it is
so if you are different in any way
you have to be really good at what you
do for people to make sure that they're
not too terrified of you
and rule number 10 the last one before
very special bonus clip is learn to love
yourself
people have decided what balance means
for everyone
for me balance is never going to mean
going to a party because that's not what
i want to do but yeah
choose your version of joy i think
people really miss out
on knowing themselves or maybe meeting
themselves
kind of later in life because they've
been doing stuff
that other people told them
was the way that we do things or what's
cool
i'm like i don't think i've ever been
cool i don't care either and
obviously i'm kidding but you kind of
got to get to this like
a great i'm gonna do me and i love me
yeah
self-love in a really true sense
that's such a hot topic right now but
then when i actually talk to people
about it i'm like but you don't
love yourself because you just talked
about yourself really negatively
for 10 minutes straight and you don't
believe in yourself and you're doing
something that yourself doesn't love to
do so you're making decisions that are
not in line with someone that loves
themself
and i think that that is kind of the
root of
how can you be confident if you don't
love yourself how can you be
fully into another person in a
relationship or into a career or
whatever
if you don't love yourself right but
part of me sometimes at least for me
giving myself a bit of like hate
actually helps
i don't always just say you're great you
can do it i love you no matter what it's
like no lisa you're sure and if you want
to be good
you've got to step up your game yeah but
it helps me it doesn't erode my
self-esteem though and i think that
that's almost what you're saying right
that yeah
if if you let it hold you back then i
think that's dangerous because it's
running your life
but if you actually use it to propel you
then i think at least for me it can can
be helpful
yeah you just need the balance of the
hate and the love
yeah i would argue like you don't hate
yourself
but i get it there's a there's a i don't
think you let yourself
off the hook that is a balance of give
yourself grace
but also like go for it i couldn't take
any of the risk that i take in any like
realm of my life
if i wasn't like at the end of the day
i know me and i'm okay with who that is
my whole self-worth comes on how have i
been like treating other people that's
really it
it's you know have i
given what i could give i'd love this
concept this idea that like
you're laying on your deathbed and
you're like i could not have given
any more there is no what if scares me
so much more
than a risk of current present failure
when i'm 100 and i'm going out is this
is there going to be even a fleeting
moment of
what if i had tried that i can't live
with that i cannot deal with that
now i've got a special bonus clip on how
to be firm that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that aside for the
question of the day i want to know
from these 10 amazing lessons from
confident woman what have you
learned the most that you're going to
apply to your life let me know put it
down in the comments below and if you
made it this far in a video you're still
here watching i want to celebrate you
because believe nation we don't just
watch videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action immediately after watching this
video give me a hashtag believe down in
the comments and tell me where you're
from
because i want to celebrate you do you
have certain things that you tell
yourself
do you call yourself on anything like
that um
one thing that i've been trying to do is
to take the word just out of my
vocabulary
instead of saying like oh i just wanted
you to try this and you know but it's
not just
it's like i want you to do this and
really being
firm about what you want and not caring
what other people think about how you're
saying it
and for me it's been really tough
navigating management employees and
stuff like that because your con
every move that you make is constantly
being watched by everyone in addition to
the
millions of followers of people watching
you too like you're being watched all
the time
and so i do want to be careful by my
words i want to be careful of people's
feelings at the same time
i can't let other people's feelings
hinder my vision
and i think for the past several months
i've been really struggling with that
and i think
it has hindered it a little bit but no
more i'm not letting that happen anymore
and so usually um i talk to sam
and he'll let me know what he's seeing
from an outside perspective and
a lot of times it's that i just am too
sensitive to caring about what the other
person is thinking
that i can't do what i want to do so and
i wish i could have a piece of what you
have which is really like
boom like you get into meaning you know
what you want you say what you need to
say
and you're just so firm sometimes i wish
i could just like pop a pill and be like
okay
harden the heart say what you need to
say and then
then you get back to normal and so for
you is it like taking it back a notch
like in back the fun the firmware yeah
and for me it's about
upping the firmware yeah yeah you feel
like that's obviously to your detriment
oh absolutely because then it makes you
feel like you're not confident
and all this stuff but it's like i am
actually really confident but i'm so
concerned about how you're gonna take
this news
that it makes me sound like i don't know
what i'm talking about that's when
you begin losing your ground and losing
your
respect and your authority or whatever
and so um how do i deal with it is i
just
i gotta practice in my head like hey
you're gonna say this you're not gonna
say the word just
um don't apologize if you don't need to
apologize because it's just because it
sounds nice like hey i'm sorry but could
you like no it's like
hey i really like how this thing looks
can you make it look like that like boom
period that's it it's business right
we're not um in work like you're not
necessarily there to be best friends if
you are that's amazing
but we're here to be a team and to make
the customers and the fans happy
so whatever we need to do to get that
done in a nice positive manner then
that's what we're gonna do
what's up believe nation i just want to
say a huge thank you
for watching this video and to my homie
evan for putting it together
on my show women of impact i'm always
looking to highlight just
badass women who have mind-blowing
stories
stories of courage resilience and
strength
but also just as importantly stories of
failures that led to their successes
stories of their fears but they just
kept going anyway
the real no holds bad truth to what it
actually takes for these women to have
gotten to where they are today
so if you like the taste of what you've
seen go over to check out
more badassery on my women of impact
youtube page
and until next time guys remember you
are the hero of your own life peace out